Find the natural log of
3 using a calculator.
Round your answer to
the nearest hundredth.
And just as a reminder,
natural log of 3,
this is just another way
of saying log base e of 3,
or what power do I have
to raise e to to get to 3?
And 3 is a little bit
larger than e. e is 2.71
and it goes on and on and on.
So 3 is a little
bit larger than e
so I'm guessing it's going to be
one point something something.
So let's get our calculator
out and just calculate it.
So natural log-- that's this
button right over here--
ln-- I'm assuming it's
maybe from French log
natural or something like
that-- So natural log of 3
is one point-- and they want
us to round to the nearest
hundredth.
So it's 1.09, but
the thousandths place
is an 8, which is greater
than or equal to 5
so we want to round up.
So we want to round the 9 up,
but that essentially takes us
to 10.
So 1.10.
So this is approximately
equal to 1.10 when we round
to the nearest hundredth.